ついついコンビニとかで一番くじがあると
Ｂ賞かＡ賞が出るまで回してしまいます
はじめしゃちょーです
あの、気付いた時には遅かったんですけども
だいぶ昔に
ゼルダの伝説
ゼルダの伝説の一番くじがあったみたいです
で、なんかその中の商品の一つに
めちゃくちゃいいものがあって
なんか、ネットとかTwitterとかで見たんですけど
こうなんか、、、、、
開けるわ！(⌒∇⌒) 一番くじも終わってるから買えなくてどうしたかって言うと
Amazonでプレミア価格で買いました
\デン/
こちらです ちょっと開けるね！
お～ちゃんと２つ入ってる
Ｄ賞なんだぁ
ゼルダの伝説の一番くじの
Ｄ賞ですね
エフェクトーンって言う物でございます。
これは謎解き正解音
こっちは、宝箱キャッチファンファーレって奴ですね
テデデデ～ン(ごまだれ～～)ってやつです。
ゼルダによく有る
効果音が流れるって物なんですけども
ちょっと開けてみましょう！
なんかぁ～開けるの勿体無いけど
開けないと使えないから。。。
バキッ
ううぇーーー
よし、來た
はいこれです↑
２つあるんですけども
まあちょっと、、使い方があるんでね
くっつけて、一定の距離離すと
「ナニモナリマセン」
違う！
なんでなんで
一定の距離離すとじゃないっけ
パラリロレロレリ♪
わぁあ
急急急、急に急に。
ＯＫ　これで一定の距離離すと、、、
パラリロレロレリ♪
って音が鳴るわけですよ
要するにこれ何かといいますと
例えばドアとかにこうやってつけときます
壁とドアにつけて
ドアが開くと
パラリロレロレリ♪
いいね！(⌒∇⌒)
これすごい欲しかったんすよ
パラリロレロレリ♪
もう１つの方ちなみにどんなのかといいますと
ごまだれ～
ｗ
すご！
パラリロレロレリ♪
ごまだれ～
はっはっはっはｗｗｗｗ
これすごい！応用できるぞ！これ
はいというわけで
今回はこのエフェクトを使って
ちょっといろんなことしていきたいと思います
マジ、ふつーに　もう　純粋に
好き♡
ちょっといろいろ遊んでいきましょう
では！
ぱぱぱぱっぱぱ～♪
ねえちょっとからまっちゃった
(ぱぱぱぱぱ～♪)
はあっ！？
ｗｗｗ
ちょっと触ってたら絡まっちゃったｗｗ
それ解いて
ちょ解けたらおしえて
ぱぱぱぱぱぁ～♪
はい
ぱぁぱぁ～♪
パラリロレロレリ♪
・・・・・・・。
ｗｗｗｗｗｗ
ぱぱぱぱぱ～♪
おぉっす！
おつかれぇ～
おつかれさまです。
あれ？
郵便ないか見てもらっていい？
～はい
ぱぱぱ～♪
ごまだれ～♪
わぁっ！
ｗｗ
なんすかこれ・・・ｗ
なんすかこれ・・・・・ｗ
ビビったぁ～
なんすかこｒ・・・
しねぇええええええええ
うわぁあああああああ
ぱぱぱっぱっぱぱ～♪
パラリロレロレリ♪
はははｗｗｗ
ぱ～ぱっぱぱぱ～♪
あれ、カメラないっけ
ビデオカメラ
どっかないかな
＃％＆？＊＠・？。
ぱぱぱぱぱ～♪
普通…ふつうのやつ・・・
＃％＆？＊＠・＋？。
ぱぱぱぱ～♪
今日外いったから・・・撮影で・・・
ぱっぱぱぱ～♪
そこにカメラは多分はいんないっすよｗ
ぱぱぱぱぱぱっぱ～♪
パラリロレロレリ♪
しまうんかいｗｗ
ぱ～ぱぱぱぱぱ～♪
ゴマダレ～♪
ｗｗｗｗ
ごまだれ～
ｗｗｗ
そこでなるんっすねｗ
ぱ～ぱっぱぱぱ～♪
ごまだれ～
ｗｗｗ
何とも言えないですねｗｗ
おい
ごまだれ～
ｗ
パラリロレロレリ♪
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
ぱぱぱぱぱ～♪
ドン！ごまだれ～♪
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
パラリロ
パラリロレロレリ♪
パラッパラリロレロ
パラリロレパラリロ　パラパラパラパラ
パラリロレロレリ♪
ハハッｗｗ